hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to an
edition of ask Evan today I'm gonna
answer a question from one of my
newsletter readers magdelena who wrote
in about trying to figure out how to
market herself better online so she
wrote insane
hi Evan I'm so grateful for having the
opportunity to get this powerful
business connection I moved to Florida
less than three years ago I've been in
helping wellness for over 18 years and
I've had my own business for 16 years I
work as a massage therapist and a
wellness practitioner and a wholeness
holistic coach I want to take my
business to a whole new level I've
started a new blog my biggest challenge
is marketing my business and myself and
getting known on the platform just
thinking about this idea and taking the
next step can be overwhelming thank you
for your willingness to help others in
business best wishes magdalena so thanks
to the question Congrats them haven't
encouraged to go out and start something
new it is a big challenge especially if
you're not technically savvy I know it
can be hard to set up online and get a
blog going and it can feel very
overwhelming so don't freak out there
are easy ways to kind of take small
steps to get yourself going if you are
using a platform like WordPress and be
really easy to post and make updates and
not feel like you're always at the mercy
of somebody who knows a lot more from
the technology side a point of view but
to answer your question on how to get
more well-known a couple of ideas for
you the first I would try to look at
guest blogging so this is a really
common way to get yourself more
well-known you basically call up our
email or get in touch with other people
who have blogs who are in your industry
so other people who are talking about
health and wellness or holistic care and
offer to write them a guest post and it
helps to have a couple topics in mind or
give them some samples or show them some
of your really best a really good posts
on your own site and then from there
offer to write a great post for them and
then link back to your site so the idea
here is you're making partnerships with
people who already have an audience you
can connect with and then have them help
promote you as well and you can get new
readers and then get them hopefully
signed up to subscribe to your blog as
well so that's a great way to get
started and usually blog owners are open
to the idea of having guest posting just
because
especially as they've had a blog for a
while it can be hard to keep content
current right it's hard to come up with
ideas all the time so having people who
are creating quality content not just
promotional pieces but really good stuff
can be a big boost to help them out as
well so that could be a good short-term
relationship but also long-term you can
contribute on an ongoing basis as well
to help drive traffic and awareness back
to your site the second thing I would do
is try to get some media so I use a
service called PR leads there are other
free services you can use as well or you
can just try to find local reporters or
online reporters who cover your space
basically idea here is you've done this
for 16 years or 18 years you know what
you're doing right it's not like you're
just starting something out from scratch
ideally as an entrepreneur you are an
expert in your field right why are you
gonna where are people gonna buy your
product or services because you know
what you're talking about so a great way
to get more exposure is to be seen as
that expert for the media so you want to
get on the radar of reporters who are
covering your space now I said I use PR
leads basically what that is the service
it's $99 a month I have no affiliation
with them other than I'm a happy
customer and you get leads from
reporters who are looking for experts
for stories it's a great opportunity to
get into media got me into the near
times and Forbes and a whole bunch of
other places but short of that you can
also create your own list and you can
try to find people who are covering
these kinds of topics and email them on
a regular basis with new story ideas or
comment on stories you've already put up
and the idea here is you want to
showcase yourself as the expert so the
next time they have a story they're
gonna come and talk to you with
reporters with any story that they
create they always want to have an
expert opinion with it right so why
can't that expert be you if you are
credible expert and you know what you're
talking about you're actually making the
reporters lives easier so you really
want to make sure you're targeting in on
a set of reporters who really focus on
your industry and get them to know you
so that's the second one so first is
guest blog and the second is get media
the third thing I would do is try to
start answering people quest people's
questions so just like I make these
youtube videos people ask me questions
and I start answering them these are
questions from my own community so you
are on my newsletter list and asking the
question so I responded if you don't
have a community yet the best question
ants are the ones around the people who
are attached to you but if you don't
have that community yet a great way to
build it is to go out and start
answering people's questions who haven't
heard of you before so I do some
research on Twitter for example I look
at forums that are related to this I
look at YouTube comments see what
questions people are asking and then
create a response for them and it could
be in the form of a blog post on your
site it could be in the form of a video
posts like this if you're comfortable in
front of the camera you could do a
podcast you can do a screencast whatever
it is you're basically answering
somebody's question if somebody has that
same question if you have lots of other
people who have the question as well and
so it shows that you're a responsive
that you know what you're talking about
hopefully you you know have some good
answers for them and then ideally as you
start building this series up you're
gonna be able to get people asking
questions directly to use instead of
just answering a random question on
Twitter or in a format and see people
are gonna start asking you questions and
you get seen as out authority figure and
people are gonna keep going back and
asking more and more questions so it's a
great way to build up if you're writing
the blog it could be you know every
Friday it's ask Magdalena and you're
answering somebody's question and the
start again is somebody else's community
but as hopefully you build up your
presence online you're able to talk to
your own people or could also be from
your your offline base so people who are
your current customers you can say here
are some frequently asked questions that
I get asked and you can create a post
around it or a video or a podcast
whatever it is so hopefully that helps I
know it can be a struggle and can seem
very overwhelming at the start to get
this thing launched remember to take
baby steps do something every day to
move it forward and then it suddenly
becomes less scary when it's this huge a
big project it's easy to get overwhelmed
and have that fear but as you start
getting into something even though it's
brand new it becomes easier and easier
the more you do it so just get started
again and look at trying to do guest
blogging try to get in with the media
and also try to answer people's
questions from different journeys online
so thanks for watching guys if you liked
the video please give it a thumbs up it
makes you want to do more of these
videos for
you and if you have a question about how
to get noticed online or different
question about your business feel free
to leave it in the comment section below
I always try to read those and try to
comment back as much as I can so thank
you and I'll see you on the next episode